stop take your finger off of that buy
now button on Amazon and do not buy an
Apple watch right now and no it doesn't
have anything to do with the recent
Apple Watch series 9 and Ultra 2 ban I
personally think that's a nothing burger
and apple will easily find a way around
that over the next couple of weeks to
undo the band The reason I'm telling you
not to buy an Apple watch right now is
because the current ones that we just
got aren't really that much different
than the Apple watch models we've been
getting for the past couple of years
save for some internal updates like the
Chip And The Brighter display but
according to some brand new leaks and
rumors next year's models could come
with the biggest redesign in the history
of the Apple watch and if you don't
believe me stick around because I'm
about to put a whole bunch of puzzle
pieces together to prove you wrong so
let's get right into those leaks way
back in August Mark Gman who is the most
reliable Apple leaker out there gave us
probably the biggest apple watch leak
ever since the rugged Ultra model leak
he said that Apple was planning a major
Apple watch 10 redesign with a thinner
casing which is always nice but more
importantly a brand new band attachment
system that would work using very strong
magnets instead of the current slide and
lock design and that right there would
be amazing for two big reasons number
one is that the current system is pretty
annoying to use because it gets jammed
all the time with the benefit of having
a very secure fit of course but number
two according to Mark German is the fact
that the current band attachment design
takes up a significant amount of space
on the inside of the watch space that
would otherwise be used to either make
the watch a lot thinner or to jam-pack
even bigger batteries into that right
there is a huge real world Advantage
even discounting the whole new magnetic
band system which by itself has a
multitude of advantages as I'm going to
explain in just a minute but
unfortunately mqu came out in October
and said that the 2024 Apple watch is
unlikely to have significant Innovation
like the new band system so it looks
like we're still a couple of years away
from getting that new massive redesign
and there's really no reason to wait if
you're looking to buy a new watch band
like one of the awesome bands from our
sponsor Nomad which is known for their
genuine leather bands cases and
accessories but what I've been
personally wearing daily all year is the
natural titanium metal band with
adjustable links for a perfect fit as
well as their Innovative magnetic clasp
system that makes it a breeze to put on
I'll leave a link to my favorite Nomad
bands down below if you want to check
them out and pick one up now back to the
leaks Mark Gman revealed that Apple's
2024 Apple watch is going to gain blood
pressure pressure monitoring and sleep
apnea detection these two features are
huge especially blood pressure
monitoring because Apple's been working
on that for many years trying to find a
solution to get it to work with just the
watch on your wrist which is a
significant Innovation compared to
having to use a traditional cuff which
is very timec consuming and you
obviously aren't going to have that on
you at all times like your watch so to
think that you could just wear an Apple
Watch and check check your blood
pressure no matter where you are in the
world is just incredible and I can see
so many people with high blood pressure
buying the Apple watch just for that
reason and then there's sleep apnea
which is also impressive because right
now the best way to detect sleep apnea
is an overnight sleep study in a medical
center which can get very expensive and
apparently Apple will be able to do this
with just the watch and the comfort of
your own bed at home once again
absolutely incredible but the most
recent leak that Mark German just gave
us a couple of days ago is the final
cherry on top apparently at least one of
the new Apple watch models in 2024 will
have an updated look which sounds pretty
vague to be honest but in my opinion it
has to be the regular Apple watch model
that gets changed because the ultra
design just came out and it's still
incredible while the series 999 uses an
identical design from the series 7 which
was already very similar to the design
language from the series 4 so what could
possibly change with the new design well
in my opinion I think it makes sense for
Apple to somehow give the regular Apple
watch a flat display and glass just like
we have on the ultra because of two
major benefits first of all having a
flat piece of glass in display combo is
actually thinner than what we currently
have on the series 9 because if you look
at this image from Apple's marketing
materials from the series 7 launch you
can see just how thick the entire piece
of glass needs to be in order to merge
into the metal Chassy seamlessly Apple
even mentioned that the glass is over
twice as thick as on the series 6 so a
thinner flat display will allow more
internal space for larger batteries and
components now the second major benefit
is the fact that flat displays are more
drop resistant because unlike the series
9 the glass on the ultra is protected by
the outer metal ring and I actually have
a pretty large gash in mind and I'm
pretty sure that if this was the series
9 I would have ended up with a cracked
display in fact I bought my wife the
series 8 last year and she unfortunately
dropped it on tile within the first week
leading to a crack display that I had to
pay to get fixed because I forgot to get
Apple Care Plus on it so a flat display
on the new series 10 would be a game
Cher and I can imagine Apple simply
reusing the same design language as they
have on the ultra but without the extra
unique design features like the cool
speaker layout the action button and the
entire protruding section on the right
side which is the crown guard just scrap
all of that give us the rest of this
design with this nice bulbous curve into
this flat design that would be perfect
but my biggest question is this if apple
is going to be changing up the design
language wouldn't it be a big enough
deal to call it the 10th anniversary
Apple watch just like the iPhone 10 and
if they're going through enough trouble
with the design change why not also
implement the new magnetic band
attachment system at the same time
because in the past whenever Apple
changed the design they kept it the same
for at least at least a couple of years
while upgrading other features so it
makes sense to do everything at once and
getting even deeper what if the new
blood pressure monitoring feature coming
in
2024 requires a brand new special
electronically connected band which
coincidentally Apple has filed numerous
patents showing bands that connect to
your watch electronically through little
pins behind the band connections and one
of those patents literally shows a band
that can tighten around your wrist
electronically which might be required
to make the blood pressure monitoring
system work and then here is the last
kicker Ross young who is the king of
Apple product display leaks said that a
new micro Led Apple watch display is
launching in
2025 this right here is a big tip
because Apple likes to split up their
upgrades between different model years
for example with their iPhone they'll
redesign the chassis one year and then
give it a huge display redesign the next
year and then a year after that they'll
give it a huge camera upgrade and the
cycle goes on so what if we are getting
the new magnetic band system redesigned
in
2024 with the micro LED upgrade in
2025 and then something else the year
after that this would totally make sense
seeing as blood pressure monitoring is
coming next year and it might require
the new electronic cuff band so what do
you think will the new design change in
2024 also come with the new band system
let me know your thoughts down below and
subscribe above for more videos like
this one thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next
[Music]
video